i just knew this city needed something
better than
the classic takeaways that's how i got
the idea for delivery
i definitely know what it was like to
walk in their shoes i did that job for a
long time
i did you know five deliveries last
night and that's why you know treating
riders with respect and making sure
their voices are heard is so important
to me
we're running low on money because we
couldn't get money in for
whatever 14 months hov it kicks off our
users were disappearing because
there are no restaurants left on the
platform so we see this plummeting
growth i had to do the hardest thing
i've ever had to do i had to
lay off you know a significant number of
people at the company
i'm so proud of what we built and i'm so
excited about the future but
it is a hard hard job and anyone that
tells you otherwise are not being honest
we're about to get all this money in the
company and then suddenly
it was just gone right
big number 600 million something like
that and i was like
holy [ __ ] you know what do we do
[Music]
delivery one of the fastest growing
technology companies in europe
you probably know the company you've
probably used it
but you probably don't know where it
came from
you probably don't know the founder and
his story
his unconventional very very humble
journey delivery went from an idea that
one guy had in london
while working in the city to becoming a
multi-billion
dollar company in record time
but the crazy thing about my
conversation today with will is
he is not your typical founder he's not
your typical ceo
he doesn't feel like your typical
entrepreneur this was really
his first business and the really
puzzling thing about my conversation
with will is he doesn't fit the typical
stereotype of what you expect an
entrepreneur to be
and i think that is amazing because it
just goes to show that
entrepreneurs don't all share the same
fundamental characteristics
they're not all these big braggadocious
characters with huge egos
and you can achieve great success with
great humility
will is an anomaly i think
you'll feel that today he is incredibly
humble
he isn't that introspective doesn't
analyze himself that much and he feels
like a very simple straightforward
character
but what he's achieved wasn't simple
it was excruciatingly difficult and as
he'll tell you today
it still is without further ado i'm
stephen butler
and this is the director ceo i hope
nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
well i am sometimes when i have guests
on this podcast i don't really know
where to start but with you it's
slightly different
um as i was reading about your story and
i've you know as i said you before we
started recording
i've been i think actually in 2015 i was
delivered delivery's biggest customer
so i'd like you to confirm that and
reward me accordingly but i think i was
um and i've watched the journey over the
years and been absolutely blown away by
it because
of the disruption you caused to such a
big incumbent industry
however when i read into your story i
kept seeing this phrase that you'd say
and it really boggled my mind because
it's so atypical of the guests i have on
this podcast
and it's that every time you're asked
about your childhood or whatever else
you'd always respond with i'm just a
normal guy
and when i think about what you've
achieved you built what is
now you know at least it was at one
point europe's fastest growing company
you couldn't possibly be just a normal
guy
i i don't know i mean i think i am you
know when you're a kid i don't think you
think anything is abnormal just
sort of is what it is um so i grew up in
a place called new haven connecticut
uh it's a small city um
about 130 000 people probably 10 square
miles so it's
pretty small um it's where uh yale
university is
oh yeah yeah so we're known for that and
we're known for
pizza those are probably the two things
we're known for best pizza in the u.s
that explains why you went and started
delivery companies i mean yeah i was
always obsessed with sally's and pepe's
and modern and all that
um but yeah look my my parents are
immigrants
um so you know i would say growing up
like
uh i guess we didn't
probably spend very much money it's
probably the best way to put it but when
you're a kid you don't you don't think
about that it's
just kind of what you
your daily existence you know your
parents what do they do
professionally my mom my mom's scientist
she works at yale
my dad uh was an actuary he retired
so they they were you know well-educated
sort of professional people
yeah and you and that brought you over
here to london
no no so so my story is i i yeah i grew
up in new haven
um i went to university in in chicago i
went to a college called northwestern
um and then my first job out of college
i worked on wall street in new york
because this was 2001.
and i took this job on i mean i did
really well in
in school both in university and in high
school
um it was just one of these jobs you did
when you kind of didn't know what else
you wanted to really do
you knew you could make money and you
knew that other
you know successful people ambitious
people kind of went down that path
so how did you end up in london i ended
up in london because i worked for three
years in new york
uh my third year they said i got another
job at a different place and they asked
me hey
do you want to you know check out a
different office and i never lived
outside the u.s
i wanted to do something different i
just took a chance literally
on london so i remember really well it
came out in april 04.
never been europe never been to london
never been
been here and so i showed up and i had
such a great time i met
you know the people on the team and i'm
like [ __ ] it i'm gonna come i'm gonna
come for a year
and then it ended up just basically
staying and how old were you when you
when you came over here for the first
time
was 24 24. yeah i think it's so crazy so
many of my american friends they've not
left the us
and i i was reading something yesterday
about the i was i think it was in i
think it's a page in the new york times
it was talking about how important it is
to leave the us
to understand the world but then also to
appreciate the country that you have
i couldn't agree more i mean today is
july 5th right yeah exactly
yeah july 4th yesterday and you
appreciate the us
so much more once once you leave
right because everyone in the us is
always like waving flags and stuff they
don't
i mean they don't know anything else
right um but when you leave and you you
understand different societies you can
appreciate
the good and the bad of the us i'd say
yeah
i don't want to go into it but when i i
i you know we grew up in the uk and i
think europe and pretty much the world
idolizing so much about the us because
of films and movies yeah
the one thing that upon moving to the us
when i was 24 to run my business
to new york i couldn't get my head
around was the healthcare system
yeah the idea that i could get sick and
be bankrupt
yeah because there's nothing you can do
about it yeah that's the only well
there's a couple other things with guns
which we weren't going to either but
that's the bits where i'm like oh my god
this isn't the so you were in new york
kind of the same age i moved to london
then yes and you moved to you
you were the williams sorry then yeah
straight to williamsburg our office was
in manhattan
so but so you're you're working in
canary wolf i'm guessing if you're in
finance
yes i was a morgan stanley um and i
remember my first
day i showed up for work because in new
york you got 25
dinner allowance you can order whatever
you want
actually funny story my first kind of
day at work in 2001
i was pretty cheap right so i was like
25 i can get
i can do whatever so i actually ordered
25 whoppers because burger king had this
dollar whopper special and everyone's
like what are you doing and by like day
three
the sort of novelty wore off i'm like i
gotta work 100 hours a week it's not
you know this isn't that much fun but no
the first day i got to london
i asked people we're working late i'm
like what are we doing for dinner
everyone's like oh just i don't know we
go to the tesco and i'm like what's
tesco
so we go in the supermarket and
everyone's like we're getting these
microwave meals
and i'm like wait a minute i'm like this
is not you're working like 100 hours a
week you try to aspire for something a
little bit better
so first day that's how i got the idea
for delivery
first day i moved here one of those
tesco meals just didn't cut it
i mean it was all right i mean they're
but but i mean there's just london's
like
one of the culinary capitals of the
world like why wouldn't you want
better food delivered what's that i mean
so many people have ideas right so many
people have ideas for big grandiose
businesses
but it's almost like and i'd hate to say
this because it sounds super pessimistic
but the odds are you're gonna fail
so how dare you how do you try and
build that you know that massive
logistical operation that is
delivery you know honestly um
it's a really good point right because
you you're aware that there's the
possibility of failure
i don't know when i went into this when
i started it i just said
i'm not hedging myself in any which way
i'm not doing side projects
i'm just gonna focus on this because i
really really believe it
not so much to start a business i
believe in it as a consumer
right so i always thought about it as
you know i'm building this business for
myself
as a consumer and hopefully other people
also
you know kind of think similarly to me
and i was convinced that enough people
did
and so i'm not one of these people that
was like oh i need to start a business
i'm like
i need to solve this problem which i
think is pretty different
in my mind and i think people should
start businesses because they want to
solve a problem
or they they're in an industry that they
know super well they've identified some
inefficiency
that's my view at least i i complete you
know over the last three years i've
heard this narrative that like
it's much easier to start a business
solving a problem that you and your best
friend
care about yeah right yeah otherwise
like you're gonna get bored
yeah you know you i i told this story
before it's totally true i had a friend
from business school
super smart guy and he he was he had
like a thousand ideas he'd write them
all down
but his ideas were all predicated on
some financial outcome right
and he started this thing it was the
etsy for pets
pet accessories or whatever and i was
like
okay this sounds okay sounds okay i read
his deck and i'm like wow this is like
like a great idea so he's like i'm gonna
go do this
and then like nine months later i'm like
okay how's it going he's like
you know what i just really don't like
dogs and cats very much and so i just
couldn't do it
right that's true you can't do something
that you're not
actually fully invested in so many
entrepreneurs will say that they'll say
oh no not even entrepreneurs so many
people that are aspiring to start a
business will say that phrase they'll
say
i really want to be an entrepreneur i
just need an idea and then you'll see
them kind of like go and write down a
list of things that they could maybe do
and whenever i see that and i this i
just 100 stand by this i always think
they're going to fail
because of the reasons you described
there because you know they're going to
go through that absolute [ __ ] chaos
yeah and i think it was steve jobs that
said the same person would quit
it when you go through the absolute
chaos so you have to love it and really
understand it it can't be
because i think i'll make because you
probably won't make money either right
no you won't right or
you you can't go in with the assumption
you will
quickly quickly as well right yeah and
you know and i
had this other guy i knew who he was
like you know what i
i he worked at a big consulting firm and
he was mckenzie or something like that
and he's like
in my spare time i've started these
three businesses and i'm like
i'm like no man you can't do that like
you pick one thing you gotta like really
go for it
different people have different sort of
attitudes towards that my view though is
you you just have to go all in right so
speaking of going all in there must have
been a day where you
hand in your notice of resignation well
so so no not not for delivery because my
story is um so
after morgan stanley i worked uh
kind of 0406 in london for morgan
sailing
and then i ended up working at a hedge
fund for about uh four years in london
and then i went back to business school
in in philadelphia for two years and it
came back in 2012.
oh let's start this business fine yeah
fine so you came back
so this was the thing i i i wanted to do
after business school
okay so you finished business school and
you came straight to london to start
yeah because
what was cool about business school was
i saw offline
online happening right because remember
i so i tried to start the live room 08
right and when i was still working in
london and when i
looked into it it was like all right i'd
have to put
a laptop in each restaurant i'd have to
build
some sort of handheld device for our
rider network
and it was just too complicated but you
know steve jobs then invented this thing
that completely changed everything right
phones tablets
all of that and so that was the
prerequisite step of course for any of
these
well any business today really to
operate right
because in oh eight iphone one came out
sdk
i think the ios sdk came out in 08 so
this app ecosystem hadn't really
developed yet
and so had to wait for that i didn't
know obviously that
the iphone would you know do what it did
but in business school i was just super
excited about it
it goes to show how critical timing can
be in terms of these macro factors with
technology
to enable ideas like that because you're
right you could never have started this
business in 2008.
that would have just been impossible and
you think i think the same about things
like spotify
all of these macro factors of handheld
devices and 5g streaming
and 4g streaming whatever all had to
come together for you even to have that
conversation with the record labels
totally
the infrastructure you know i mean you
think back to
to just laying cables under the atlantic
i mean all of this stuff right
to to to the to the iphone to all the
software that was being built on i mean
just crazy
what had to come before and and those
changes are always happening because the
of the rate of evolution of technology
so it goes to show
that right now because of what's
happened over the last
x amount of months there are new
opportunities being that have been
created for entrepreneurs
whether it's blockchain or crypto or so
i think even as an entrepreneur you
always think all the good ideas are
taken
and you know for us we're obsessed about
continual
innovation of course because we know
competitors come for us right
we know that there's going to be someone
sitting around going man this delivery
thing kind of sucks we gotta like we can
do better than that right and so we're
paranoid about that all the time
right that's how we think about it we
always think we can get a lot better
we have to so so when you first started
out in london so you've moved from
business school you've
you've got this idea um talk me through
how
you know as a ground floor opportunity
how that became a
a conceptual like a business yeah so um
it was me and my co-founder greg
so greg and i grew up in new haven
together we've been friends since i
think we're like 12. wow right
yeah and so we were into computers like
when we were 12. i mean this is before
i'm trying to think here because my mom
worked yale so
we would go use the um the unix
workstations there and
we we actually you know like we were on
these use net groups
um you know we were using ftp this is
all before there was really a true
graphical representation of the internet
and so we got and we got pretty into
computer games and stuff like that so we
were we were pretty into that stuff
um and and so that's how i that's how i
knew my co-founder greg
um we then kind of got out of computers
a bit i don't know just discovered
different things
um but he ended up just you know staying
well he he studied history then worked
as a car mechanic
just kind of randomly because he liked
cars so he just
decided to do that and then he started
becoming a software developer again
and so him and i we would discuss ideas
like all the time and so
in oh wait i talked to him about this
idea right deliveroo
and he was like we thought about it he
was like this is really complicated for
all the reasons we just talked about
but we stayed in very close touch so
throughout business school i was always
like hey man what do you think about
you know this thing again i think it's
like possible and so i convinced him to
quit his job
and you know kind of start this thing
with me
but i moved to london he stayed in the
states
so it was kind of like this weird thing
right but i would say so i moved back
here on october 12th
um we were building the prototype uh the
restaurant tablet
um the rider app um we didn't actually
launch with a consumer app we
literally just had a website and so you
had to kind of if you had a phone you
had to kind of zoom in to all the
buttons
it wasn't even mobile optimized we
didn't meant them an app right so
and and so yeah because there's two of
us right and so um
i'd say the first few months before
launch it was like me trying to set up
restaurants i signed up restaurants
walking up and down the street
in chelsea it was him building all the
initial technology
me and him making product decisions so
it's just just
basically two of us then he came out for
the launch january
13 and we launched in feb 13 and
um yeah it was just me and him for the
first
i guess year yeah so you were
predominantly leading the rider side in
the kind of like on the ground operation
i mean there's two of us so there's
literally
not like i mean greg was building all
the technology yeah
he did it himself which is like pretty
incredible i was working with them on
the product decisions
and then i was running the business but
the business was me signing up
restaurants
me you know getting getting the rider
side of the marketplace going
um and obviously you know attracting
consumers
but the funny thing is you know
initially when we launched in february
obviously no one knew who we were so
i would actually just ask my friends to
order all the time
and you know they just get annoyed at me
like why are you like bothering me like
what
and um a number of my friends would
would order i know for the sole purpose
of
watching me deliver the food to them
right and i know that for sure
and they they just thought it was like
funny they would do the same yeah so i
would deliver the food
and then they they'd want to chat i'm
like sorry guys i gotta go do my next
delivery
um but then i realized one thing after a
while
they kept ordering even if i didn't
deliver the food and so that's when i
kind of
realized we were onto something do you
remember the
first order that wasn't your friend
oh um no i i honestly don't but i can
tell you
the first order though the first first
order ever
i mean i told her to order it was it was
my friend anetta
and she was living on sydney street in
chelsea and the restaurant was rosso
pomodoro
and i and you know i was like excited
because she ordered so i delivered it
but i delivered the pizza upside down
yeah so it was it became a calzone um
and then i then i just ate it and she's
like you ruined my meal and you ate the
food this is like the worst experience
of all time
yeah only up from there though so it's
good i mean the writer ate the order
yeah yeah not only you delivered it
terribly and then ate the food
but but still charged her i'm guessing i
might have given her a refund i think
i don't know for any kind of video but
no that was that was what happened right
it was like
my friends were ordering and then it was
just word of mouth right and and people
got
you know the bunch of people started
just showing up never i didn't know
their names
i had no idea what's going on and i
heard you you didn't do marketing for
the first
couple years a couple years yeah yeah
well i did one thing i had to
i used to wear this kangaroo costume
around um
yeah yeah um i didn't really enjoy doing
that but um i
i would wear a kangaroo costume and hand
out these um
you know whatever like this is the
living room yeah
well why why london and not america i
guess america's way more competitive and
the design of the country is slightly
different but why london
well i mean i'm a londoner right i lived
here for six years before going back to
business school
i just knew this city needed something
better than than the classic takeaways
wow whatever you don't have to say i'll
say it just you it's [ __ ] awful
what you know i don't know back in the
you don't have to say i'll say it um
when i was a student getting the cold
stodgy
awful rest not even restaurants awful
corner shop takeaways and styrofoam
boxes that was cold was just
awful and there was no yeah and so
my first experience with delivery was
when i think i said you off camera
um a company that i was working with
turned the ceo turned around to me and
said you can now
order from top class restaurants and it
comes in a nice pack
nice packaging and i thought there's no
possible [ __ ] way
and then i tried it and i never went
back well the reality is look i tried
you know um just eat back in 0.7 right i
was really excited about it i was like
this is going to be like new york and i
tried it i'm like oh wait i can't track
my order
i don't know when the food's going to
show up and it was all
sort of look i like kabobs right i like
fractures nothing wrong with that
but if that's the only choice yeah i'm
kind of like you know
i like kebabs but my intestines don't so
like it's a very
there's a battle there's some good
places there's something no that's true
there is there is there's a couple of
slightly healthier options for kebabs
around this around this area
um but then so you get to the point
where there's i read about there was a
couple of riders so there was you and
the three
or four others yeah um there was mirza
there there's saeed there's hanif um
sayed and hanif and mirza still work
with us
um doesn't uh there's about four of us
yeah and they're still writers three of
them are one of them
actually works in our office in dubai
now oh wow he does like rider
support in dubai he wanted to move to
dubai so amazing yeah
awesome and so you guys were this was
when the business was starting to get a
little bit of traction within chelsea
i'm guessing exactly yeah yeah so a
little bit of traction in one
neighborhood
yeah we we launched only in one
neighborhood right the first
you know a few restaurants were on the
fulham road in the kings road
and one of the restaurants was was my
landlord's restaurant i used to live
above it
so he i convinced him to sign up for
just because he was like i saw him every
day
right it's so funny because when you
hear about the lean you know when you
read books
like the lean startup and you hear about
how entrepreneurs should be starting
businesses
you seem to have done a lot of things
accidentally right
like even your your idea of launching in
a small area whether you can establish
network effects and
not necessarily doing marketing
advertising to your friends stephen we
didn't have money
yeah this wasn't silicon valley i'm
gonna raise a 30 million dollar seat i
was funding the business myself
so it wasn't like i had a choice right
and so i'm kind of like okay i don't
want to like
burn all my cash you know and so that's
kind of how i was running the business
until we actually raise money
there's something important about that
isn't there when teams don't have huge
budgets they seem to make better
decisions
i think so i i think i actually do i
think having too much money
can be problematic um and there's a lot
of money now
but yeah when you're when you're it's
just me and greg
four riders like 10 restaurants
you know you don't have any money yeah
you gotta like just
work on the most important things and
try to be as efficient as possible
i resonate with that because i when i
started my first business we had six
thousand pounds marketing budget
and it was it wasn't until we'd blown it
all on all the conventional [ __ ]
flyers posters some inflatable balloon
which we rolled down a road
and we had no money that we sat there
the three of us and and said
um if we have no money how do we get a
million people yeah how do we do it
and that led us to discover this thing
called social media yep and then
um we were like well this well this is
facebook page that has 8 000 students on
it
and the owner says we can buy off him
for 50 quid i've got 50 quid let's go
meet him
bought it posted about my website on
this facebook page more traffic than
we've ever had so we were like
let's just build facebook pages for free
and so in 2013-12
we started building facebook pages we
got to 100 million followers we're doing
seven billion video views a month
and the business grew to be worth 300
million and it would never have happened
if we didn't run out of money because we
were forced
to think in real first principles
exactly to ignore convention
and um so i i came up with i i think
i i love this idea i i'm like that's
like my proudest idea
so um we we were like okay look how do
we reach people we could do the flyers
i was sick of walking around with this
kangaroo costume right and so
i was like hmm and i was staying in a
hotel and
i was like oh they have these do not
disturb signs that you can hang on the
door
right you know when you're in a hotel
like do not disturb and i'm like you
know what we should just
say deliveroo and then list a number of
the restaurants in the local
neighborhood because no one knew you
could actually get deliveries from there
and we just hung them on people's doors
and that worked
so no discounts nothing just letting
people know about it it cost you what
20p for one of these things right
funny thing is the police got real mad
because they
we didn't think about this at the time
the police called us and they're like
what is this delivery thing we're like
well we're a food delivery company
they're like
how do we know you're not a burglary
ring
and a robbery ring and i'm like what are
you talking about they're like well you
could
just leave those on people's doors and
see who doesn't take them off and if
they're
if they're still on the houses are
vacant so you could burglarize them and
i'm like
i didn't really think about it that way
but pretty genius idea actually
yeah and you're sitting there in your
kangaroo outfit trying to convince the
police you're not a burglar
basically do you want to come in and
watch this podcast live from behind the
scenes if you do
all you have to do is hit the subscribe
button and now that the world has opened
up
you'll be behind the scenes as many of
our subscribers have been i can't wait
to meet you
so i you know you've got four or five of
you um the riders riders yeah
and you're i hear that you're hanging
out in a starbucks
often and you're just sitting there
chilling waiting for someone to
yeah we're just talking i mean you know
you know there's like four of us
there yeah do you the founder of the
company and three others
the three riders yeah just waiting for
the phone to ping
yeah it was the three of us and it was
the same guy would come to us and he'd
be like all right you guys got to leave
we're like but we we bought something
you know
he's like kick us out every every time
you know
and why was he kicking you out i don't
know to be honest i don't think he liked
the look of us
if i'm honest with you um
yeah you know like like uh i i think um
you know and one day i went to him and i
go what is your problem like
you know and he's just like get out
right and it was the way
that he looked at us the way he looked
at me was almost like we were
not people right we're kind of like
anonymous is probably the best word i
could use and then sort of sub human is
probably
you know the the worst word i could use
but it was like that like we're just
taking up space in this thing or
making his coffee shop look kind of
crappy right
and i remember talking to the three
other guys about it
they like they're just like whatever
just let it go like
like who cares but i realized that that
must be how a lot of people look at them
all the time right because they're used
to it right and for me i wasn't really
used to it so i was like really really
mad about it
but you know it i definitely know what
it was like to walk in their shoes
you know for a day well for i guess a
whole year because i did that job for a
long time
and that's why you know treating writers
with respect and making sure
their voices are heard is so important
to me
because of you know that one of those
incidents and then those three
those three guys were from pakistani
descent yeah
so one would one could assume that
the the reason why the gonna definitely
assume that yeah yeah i
was assuming just to be completely clear
i was assuming and
yeah and asserting yeah well they're
just like the way you know they're
looking at us like uh these these people
are gonna make my store look shitty you
know you could tell right
and so yeah that that was a kind of
seminal moment i think
for me and and just talking to these
guys but they were just so
sort of like either jaded or
kind of numb to it they're like wow like
whatever it seems to happen in them
all the time yeah because they
experience that type of prejudice
and discrimination all the time i i mean
i've i've been there right so
very early and that's why that
particular story resonates with me a lot
is because i remember
very early on when i was launching my
business i have a tendency to to
wear snapback caps and hoodies even
today
and obviously my net worth is
significant now and so when i get into
like the first class part of the train
i'll never forget the day whether the
train attendant walks right down the
aisle past everybody else and goes
this is first class mate you're like
yeah
didn't didn't mention that to anyone
else yeah just felt they need to come up
to me and my snap back because i'm
wearing this cap in this hoodie
and tell me some assumptively that this
this is this is first classmate i'm just
looking at him thinking
yes i know yeah you know what i mean and
it's funny because i wrote it in my
diary this is how i still remember this
incident
i wrote in my diary that one day you
know i'll you know
i hopefully this wouldn't be the case
that people were you kind of like
numb to it or were you kind of angry
angry yeah
angry but for me it's like this small
little
heat inside it's not like i'm gonna be
rude to you yeah but
it's like you presume something about me
and and to be honest
there's a bit of me that actually
it's in some ways a compliment that he
couldn't possibly think someone like me
could
afford to sit there and for me that
there's some kind of
compliment in there because of the
underestimation that a black kid
that's young can't sit in first class
you know
not that it's a right thing but it's it
is what it is well i guess for me though
what it also highlighted to me like was
how lucky i was
relative to some of these guys that they
they cam
they come from backgrounds of you know
extreme poverty growing up in
in in in pakistan they came here to
build a better life they're super hard
working
like super dedicated and someone's just
treating them like [ __ ] it's like
it's pretty bad yeah it's an experience
you i think few would understand if they
hadn't
been through it themselves so at some
point in this podcast i usually do a
break to talk about huel who are the
sponsor of this podcast
but me and will spent so long talking
about the product i thought i'd just
show you this clip instead
you know what i will try this you're
going to try it do you like drink this
in lieu of a meal three times a day so
you just stopped eating
hey deliveroo man do you know what
actually it's crazy because that is that
has been a pretty exciting
yeah no well i i think i i had delivery
this no i did i had delivery this
morning okay in fact the wrap the
package is over there so i got at 7 30
this morning
and then when i'm busy throughout the
day where i'll and i'm moving this but
you enjoy
food you enjoy yes okay but i know we'll
never
give up hard food try it let me know all
right so let's see here we got
the whole bottle is 400 calories 32
carbs
20 grams of protein man let's try it out
low fat gluten-free sawyer
it's it's not nest quick okay it's
cool this actually tastes pretty good it
is listen and it will
leave you feeling energized and full
and honestly we get addicted around here
so jack um
who directs the podcast when we put in a
huel fridge downstairs he hadn't had it
before tries one and now he actually
lives off it
if i drink this am i gonna want to eat
food as well
no okay no chance so so it's a good way
to like
yes lose weight and all that kind of
stuff yes oh no chance i wonder if i can
buy this on delivery maybe
um you talk about the very early days of
delivery one of the things that founders
struggle with a lot and i did as well is
is the name of the company and i heard i
was reading about that
oh no yeah but i love this story because
i think it highlights how crappy
some decisions are at the start i heard
you were going to call delivery
something else
yeah there were there were a few
different um permutations
one was a food pony because i didn't
read about that because i was thinking
of these
animals and food i think one was
um i think it was i'm trying to think
here it was like uh
yeah it was food mule was was another
one because
you know a mule's uh transports um
food not so good right what about booze
food did you forget that one yeah
i didn't think you'd mention it um so
the original idea for deliveroo even
this is before 08 right
so you know you this so in new york
you go out on a big night first of all
everything's open like really late
right so you can actually go out past
11. if you get home at like five in the
morning you can still
order something to eat like you can do
that and what my experience in in london
was you
go out late and you just can't actually
eat anything and i just like
couldn't understand that and so
initially the idea for delivery was
something called
the zo7 it's called booze food which you
know really allowed you to order food at
like 3am when you really wanted it
so that is actually true yeah it's funny
because when
people look at successful founders
there's this like weird assumption
that all of the decisions you made were
right and that you're super smart and
that you got everything right
and it's not until you go back into
those early moments and dig through some
of the thinking the marketing ideas
you think [ __ ] hell this is someone
that's actually
developed their thinking oh it's just
iterating right yeah you know
um but the boost food idea so there's
there's another funny part of that
because when when delivered so
boost food was a separate thing but then
when my buddy tried to liver for the
first time
he was like oh yeah this is great like
you've got
busaba you've got rosso pomodoro you've
got all these great restaurants in
chelsea
but he's like really what you need to do
is have a cheat code
so when you're really drunk you can put
in some cheat code and then it's like
literally like all the bad stuff for you
so that
maybe we'll implement that at some point
i don't know you chose to ignore him
that's pretty funny idea
interesting um talking about co-founders
another sort of
integral part of success in business
how um how did things go with greg
i i know that he's no longer in the
business but he at some point he
departed
yeah yeah no i mean look without greg
the business wouldn't exist
right no no question about it i think um
you know he's one of the smartest uh
hardest working people i know
we grew up together he's one of my best
friends we've been friends since we were
12.
um i think um for greg he
he wouldn't move to the uk um ever
he just wouldn't do it never yeah i
guess he didn't you know he's too
american i don't know
but no he he his wife was in a um she
was getting a remd
degree in the u.s and so it was like
hard for him to like come over here
and ultimately you know at some point so
he built a
um engineering team in chicago where he
was living
but at some point i was like no this
this business real like we gotta
we gotta have the team all together and
so you know made a decision and he
he he left a business in late 15 early
16 or so um but i mean i have a great
relationship
with him we were just chatting last
night but yeah
founders go through hell together yeah
yeah i mean my founder co-founder did
yeah we went
we went through a lot but you know it
was tough when he left right because i
didn't have um
there's not someone i can talk to on
that same level right
yeah you've got your you know your your
southern sort of other execs and
you've got you know a board of directors
but it's different
it's it's really different than having
that did that hurt you when he left
did it hurt me yeah a bit right because
i was kind of like
kind of wanted to build this thing you
know with him
but i also wasn't willing to just have
half of the company be based in the
states i just didn't think that was the
right thing to do for the business
right um yeah and i think it was um
yeah you know it was uh yeah it was
tough right
it was tough do you think that situation
could have been handled differently
in hindsight i think i think maybe i
could have convinced him a little bit
more to
to move out here i just think because he
wasn't here
he didn't actually understand the
momentum of the business
but he didn't see all the stuff on the
ground for him it was an abs
it was an abstract idea i mean you can
see the metrics you can see all that but
that's really different
than seeing a bunch of you know delivery
riders the backpack on and
sort of people talking about it in the
uk right
but i mean look i i think i think would
have been great if he if he stuck around
but
i also think that you know people make
certain decisions and
he he decided to prioritize an another
thing which is
you know totally totally fine i find
that really interesting as well and the
reason i asked that question about do
you think it could have been resolved
differently is because the world is very
much changed now because of covid
and we have distributed teams all around
the world in startups now yeah
and this was pre way pre-coverage 2015
before zoom probably
even you know had taken off so just i
just wonder if now in the world we live
in now
a relationship where the tech team is
remote could have
i i think i i do think and by the way
much of our tech team today is remote
but the difference is
we still have a very big core of people
that kind of have seen the journey
up front and center and so when you
layer on top of that remote people i
think that works really well
i think to have a product team and a
technology team that
literally never uses the product because
they're in the states is a really
problematic in my mind
because ours is not a just a pure
digital product right we're
we're a digital and a physical product a
relationships business
that's what it is right and so it's it's
different than you know something that's
purely
your experience in chicago and london is
the same on certain types of businesses
for us it's very different
true very true talking about going
through hell with founders and
co-founders and just generally the hell
of starting
startups um one of the real reasons i
founded this podcast was because and
it's kind of clued in the name
is because i didn't feel like the full
journey of a founder is ever really told
specifically the hard parts um and
i i know that in your journey to build
the business you did you've confronted
all kinds of
awful challenges yeah right talk to me
about some of those awful challenges
especially at the start
it doesn't get easier i'll tell you that
right so i mean the business is
really you know significantly sized
business now but i wouldn't say it gets
easier
they're just different right so you're
one i would say the big challenge is
no money you know me and greg running
around
right um i think my biggest challenge
was at some point so i think i was lucky
in the sense the business momentum
sort of did take it wasn't like super it
wasn't like this but
there were new customers and we we knew
this thing was working
but i didn't know how big it was it
would be and at some point because i was
delivering food every single night right
and at some point i remember my my
flatmate he went to business school with
me
faris and he he kind of looks at me and
he's a good friend of mine right he
says he's like what are you doing and
i'm like what do you mean he's like you
just
deliver food for five hours every night
that's like what you do
and i'm like yeah because i gotta who
else is gonna do it and he was just like
he kind of looked at me and just like
all right you know and then i
kind of like because because i you know
i worked in these
jobs that you can you know make a lot of
money before i i
had this summer internship at wharton
that was like the one everyone wanted
and i just
decided to do something else and um no
he was kind of like
he thought i was like losing my mind
right and then i thought of it because
i'm not a very
like i don't even think i'm that
introspective to be honest so i don't
i'm kind of like i got stuff to do i'm
gonna like do it and so he was like hey
man you should like think about
what you're doing right and i did
and i was kind of like freaking out a
bit just like sitting in my in my small
room like
what am i doing right am i where is this
gonna go and then i just was like
you know [ __ ] it like i think this is
going great so i'm gonna i'm gonna stick
to it
so that was hard um i would say um did
you come close to
quitting at that stage no i never did
really
never greg did though yeah
greg did i never did i'm not like i just
i just wouldn't you know i wouldn't let
that happen why
i don't know man they just i just feel
like
i have such responsibility to the people
i i work with the restaurants and the
writers and
i don't know you just start like i'll
tell you what i'm not i'm not one of
these people
you know you read about bezos like hey
i'm going to start with books books are
easy to transport i'm going to move on
and all these other things
it's grand plan in their mind not like
that at all
but what i did see was i saw success
that fuels more ambition
you get into the circular path and so i
was i was on it like that and i just
also have this just immense sense of
responsibility to people
right similar to that story you told
about your friend there
i read that you one day knocked on a
door to deliver some food and it was one
of your
former colleagues from yeah from a hedge
fund yeah
yeah i find this fascinating because
people don't often talk about
embarrassment
as being one of the real key barrier to
entries to start businesses and to
pursue your
your dreams yeah but it's such a tough
barrier
like humiliation and embarrassment and
that look i remember that look fondly of
the people i was living with when i was
18 19 and you tell them what you're
doing
and that kind of like smirky like oh
okay
yeah that happened i also i mean that
story yeah so
it's john luca and um really nice guy
but
so i'd worked with him probably five
years before and he hadn't seen me in
like five
years and so he he ordered something i
didn't know it'd be him
and i deliver this pizza to him and i
got my my scooter helmet on
and he's like i'll do his accent it's
pretty strong he goes will
is that you are you okay he's italian
right he's from naples
and i'm like i'm like who the [ __ ] is
this i'm like oh it's john luke i'm like
hey uh i'm like hey john luca
and he's like is that anything okay you
know he's like he just thought i like
lost my mind
um so because he didn't really
understand that i started the business
he
oh i just i think he thought i was you
know just delivering pizzas right
and i'm like well yes i am delivering
pizzas but i also that is part of the
job but you know i also started this
business and he just
thought it was totally nuts yeah
a lot of my friends did in the beginning
though that first year a lot of them did
i mean they were supportive but
you know i knew what they were kind of
saying behind my back a little bit too
you know
not not in a terrible way just like out
of concern
why didn't you care too busy
too busy man i generally don't care
i generally don't care what other people
think if i'm honest with you my whole
life never really have
i don't know why but a bit of a
superpower isn't it
i don't know could be a good thing could
be a bad thing don't know just don't
really care that much
it's definitely a good thing it's
definitely a good thing especially as it
relates to your personal happiness but
also pursuing your
your um your goals and ambitions because
as we say embarrassment and
and because public scrutiny seems to be
one of the biggest barriers to starting
and continuing
so when you get past that initial stage
what are the next big challenges
um so post year one business starts
getting some traction
maybe business starts getting traction
um that part's real exciting right you
know you raise your first amount of
money that's like
super exciting it's like wow someone
someone gave
i think with us it was index ventures
gave us 2.7 million pounds
which now you're like that's like the
smallest seed thing that ever
do but but i was like wow like we've got
you know this
these really smart guys that want to
invest in the business um
and now it's about like how do we scale
this thing
and so it was hard but it was a lot of
fun right
but i didn't know how to like hire
anyone i'd worked in finance and i
worked at hedge fund
sat in front of a bloomberg machine
right so i'm just
on gumtree that's how i hired and
actually the people people that that
work at delivery now they don't they
always
tell me that's not true but it's 100
true i hired the initial people from
gumtree
and i was just like writing like random
like job descriptions
and we ended up um getting an office
by office i mean probably the size of
this room i would say
no windows no heating it's definitely
illegal it was on cleveland street
121d cleveland street and um
we we found these like tables and chairs
in the car park beneath it
found a sofa on the street just set it
up it was a thousand pounds a month
and we got going right but i loved that
part that was so much fun
um so i'd say in the like the first two
were super hard
i would say years two and three
and four were hard but like exciting
because you're expanding the business
you don't
really know what you're doing you're
kind of figuring it out as you go along
right so i love that part your favorite
part
yeah i'd say my favorite part is
definitely when the company's like
20 to 100 people yeah look i'm the i'm
i'm the ceo of a large publicly traded
company now right it's not gonna be as
fun let's be honest
like and i'm happy to say that on the
record yeah like
everyone does everyone talks about the
sub hundred
um because you know why because
everyone's on the same page yeah
you don't need to be deliberate about
communications you don't need to be
deliberate
about how all the pieces fit together
everyone just kind of knows
and obviously to scale a company and do
that in a high quality way you need to
figure out the systems to do that
so that when you have 3 000 people it's
similar to when you have a hundred but
when you have 100
i think it's the best you know
everybody's name and oh everyone's name
you guys are all
sort of kind of friends you you know you
go to the pub together
you know that's fun when did you
consider yourself to be an entrepreneur
ah i don't know i don't know if i ever
thought about it like that was there
even after you raised that money did you
did you think i'm a businessman
i always thought about i wanted to build
an online food company
that's how i always thought about it so
whether it's business or
entrepreneur i don't know i don't know
what the title means but you know
it's funny because there's i'm not
obsessed with the idea of building a
business i'm obsessed with the business
i'm building
so many people have it the other way
around i think so
and it's almost become quite i know sexy
and instagramable to be like
be your own boss i'm ceo [ __ ] like do
you know all that stuff like and i think
that
and again i just bet against those
people that are building for the sake of
status not for the sake of value right
solving a problem
yeah solve a problem so so intriguing
that seems to be a really similar
pattern with the people that sit here
that have built great businesses they
didn't they had no interest in being an
entrepreneur they just got sucked into a
problem they thought they could solve
yeah to me that's got to be the way now
obviously there's
going to be a lot of different people
different approaches but for me
absolutely that's got to be the way
so in that early stage when you just got
that office and there's you know
a couple of you in that room things are
tough right you're talking about you
know you're burning cash
all startups especially tech ones tend
to be burning cash yeah
um what was your mental health journey
from that point till now
look i'd say this um i don't know about
other people i i don't think i'm a very
up and down person uh so i guess that's
probably a good thing but i'm not
totally sure
could mean i'm just suppressing a lot of
stuff i don't really know right
but um i don't have like these enormous
ups where i'm like going around jumping
up and down
and i'm not going bananas when things
are you know kind of going
back that that being said some of my
former colleagues in the early days
might disagree with me
i would absolutely go nuts when
i thought an order was handled and
appropriately or customer service
interaction was um handled
inappropriately
i think some people probably they can
have some memories of that but
i kind of got over that and don't don't
really do that anymore but
i would say a lot of the journey
is super super super hard i'm happy to
talk about
any of those stories with you but
there's definitely been
long periods of time not just like for
hours like long periods of time we're
just like
man this is this has to get easier or
like
you know you're just i forget it was
elon musk or whoever talks about it the
standing on the abyss thing
you know you know chewing glass i felt
that like
many many many times right that's hard
it's really hard if you'd known it would
be that hard would you have started
thinking about your toughest moments if
you'd known you would have had to
go through that that chewing glass
staring into the abyss would you have
started delivering
um if on the day where you thought i'm
gonna start delivery today
i'd come and i'd shown you a tape of
those moments
yeah but i guess it's a little hard to
say because if you told me hey
business would be where it is today
would i have started it probably yes
you told me it wouldn't work out and i'd
be having chewing glass for like years
then probably not right
it all it all depends but it it's like
hard to it
completely different degree because as
the founder you think about it
every single hour you think about it you
know when you're in bed
you know when you're when you're talking
to a friend you're it's in you can't
escape it
right you touched your head there when
you said you can't escape it
that's where it is right that's where it
lives it lives in your head at all times
at all times you can't escape talk me
through the specific details of those
moments though
one example of an issue so so one of
them was
we were um so so back in 2017
holy [ __ ] i guess four years ago now
yeah
we were um you know we'd raised a bunch
of money from our
kind of investors so that was index
accel green oaks dst
you know businesses sort of flying um
and then um we were going to raise money
from
you know the world's biggest fund right
i'm not going to name who they are but
you can probably guess who they are at
some point
right um
so anyway so we were we're about to do
that
um we just term sheets signed doing due
diligence summer of 17
and um you know big round and um
all of a sudden i get a call like oh we
three days before we're supposed to
close oh we can't do this
no blah blah blah reason
i think it was related to wework it was
it was related to uber i think
okay or something like that right i
don't remember exactly the specifics but
it doesn't really matter the point is
we're about to get all this money in the
company and then suddenly
it was just gone right a big number
big number and i was like holy [ __ ]
you know what do we do so how big was
this number it's like
600 million something like that it's a
lot of money right
700 maybe i don't even remember it's a
bad day but then
we um and i was like kind of pissed off
for like 10 minutes
but i got the team together i'm like
guys we got a lot of work to do over the
next
you know month six weeks so we lined up
like
25 investor meetings all around the
world
and we just went we met with all these
other funds
and we got it done but that was that was
really really tough right
again because if we didn't get we didn't
get the money because we're lost making
entity right
we were running out of money right so
that part was not
fun that was a tough one but it was
great we ended up
you know working with um you know
fidelity and t rowe price so we
got in terrific investors so at the end
of the day you look back on it it was
like oh that's a
actually a really good outcome but at
the time it was really hard
but that is so synonymous and typical
with
building a business just that unix i
mean this year's i mean
covert 19 was an example of that just
unexpected
unpredictable unanticipated crippling
[ __ ]
at any time and this is why i find it
almost impossible for founders not to
live with some form of anxiety because
you know when you wake up
on any day there's a high probability
you're going to get a text message or an
email
that something you didn't think about
has just totally gone
well i'll tell you i'll tell you a story
about covet actually it actually
predates covet a bit so
we raised the next round of capital
um so um from amazon which you you
probably know yes
the way this happened though was was
really crazy so
we had um spent a bunch of time um with
amazon
they decided to invest you know we
negotiated the deal
all normal and they were great and we
the due diligence process i was like wow
these guys
really know what they're doing right so
it's really it was really great
so we announced the deal and again you
know we're loss making so we need the
money right
and again this is a big round and the um
the cma the antitrust authorities
in in the uk they're just like we need
to review this
but they wouldn't actually let us take
the money in
right and we're like but how are we
supposed to compete when
we compete against the likes of uber and
justine you know that are well funded
they're kind of like it's not really our
problem you know we're like well
you know we're a british company trying
to build you know big tech business here
and so that whole process was
excruciating
because it was 18 months long
[ __ ] 16 16 months 18 months long where
amazon was a minority shareholder in our
company i think a 13
stake 14 stake shareholder same as some
of the other like investors right
they had one board seat everything was
normal says and
you know these guys just literally kind
of went after
you know this um in an unprecedented way
but we couldn't get the capital in right
so we're just going we're like
what do we do and we're at the mercy
of some sort of you know institution
right it's not like a free market type
of thing you can go and like find out
you know
we're at the mercy of this situation and
so they took us through what they call
their phase one investigation
which lasted like six months and then a
phase two investigation lasts another
eight months
so that was terrible right utterly
terrible because you don't
actually have any idea what's going to
happen because it's not it's not a
logical process right
it's sort of like you know
it's the whim of someone else right it's
not it's not a logical process
at the same time what started happening
was kovid kicked off in
what jan feb of 2020 right so
we're running low on money because we
couldn't get money in for
whatever 14 months whatever it was
covet kicks off and covid what it did to
us initially was
our restaurant partners were shutting
down for delivery
and dining not just dine in right
and so the restaurants on the platform
started plummeting
you know in europe and the uk now asia
was different they handled it very
differently
but we didn't our users were were
disappearing because
there were no restaurants left on the
platform right i don't know what they
were doing i guess they're going to
ocado or whatever
and so we see this plummeting growth we
have to
and we had to do the hardest thing i had
to do the hardest thing i've ever had to
do i had to
lay off you know a significant number of
people at the company
which just was the yeah it was the
hardest thing i had to do
you know like big layoffs because we we
just didn't know what the future was
going to be like
we were in the middle of an anti-trust
process hoping to get a lot of money
in our business is plummeting
that was really bad really bad i mean
the worst for people that lost their
jobs obviously
but really bad sleepless nights
i always sleep um but yeah the days are
hard
days you cite that moment as being the
toughest in your journey at delivery
yeah i do i do just that whole
because it's it's not like a problem you
or i could solve
right if it's like hey you know we
didn't do this round
i can go and raise more capital whatever
we can go figure it out or
this feature doesn't work well the way
we wanted to we can figure out a way to
iterate around that
there's an org structure issue well we
can figure that out
but when you're at the whim of a
government institution that's a very
different feeling that's a
you're totally not in control and when
it lasts for that long then the issue is
you're a tech company you can't not
compete
hard for 14 16 months right that's not
the world the way the world works it's
not like a
two grocery chains battling it out right
it's just different
and so yeah i'd say that was hard it was
compounded with the fact that
we had to lay off all these people right
which is the hardest thing we could do
now luckily for us these restaurants
reestablish themselves and the business
has been on this
amazing trajectory that was tough
what goes into your thought process when
you realize you've got to lay off a
significant amount of people
you know that it has domino's effect
domino effects you know that it's going
to be a press story
all of these things you know that people
are losing their jobs their livelihoods
at a time when they
you know when they're going when when in
a time when the the future is so
uncertain
yeah what's going through my head like i
mean
just it's [ __ ] terrible right i don't
know what else to say
you know but do we have to do it but
it's terrible
and getting up in front of the company
and explaining to people why this is the
right thing to do
really hard these are their friends
colleagues
you know lost a lot of really great
people you know
it's definitely the hardest thing we've
ever had to do
those are the days when it sucks busy
right
look the job is like oh i'm so proud of
what we built and i'm so excited about
the future but like
it is a hard hard job and anyone that
tells you otherwise is
either having an exceptional experience
or or they're not being honest right
i also think it's different when you're
the founder and the founder ceo
right like i built the thing from an
idea
right and it's a big thing and then i
don't care about the press
i care about like our employees right
i care about the restaurant partners the
the riders
the consumers did you have anxiety at
that point
did you ever suffer with anxiety i mean
i i
certainly think so a must-have yeah
yeah for sure i i definitely had anxiety
throughout that point
running my business as well because we
face similar decisions
and you're right the key word that
you've used there which i resonated with
was uncertainty
uncertainty because it's sort of like
it's not in your
control and you don't know how when you
i knew the cma i had to deal with them
once in 2015.
and it's not as you say no timelines we
when we didn't have a timeline when we
were dealing with the cma
yeah um we know that it's it's largely a
political
yes um setting a presidency you know for
us it was we were the biggest in our
industry so
they were trying to establish a rule by
using us
as an example did you go through a phase
one or what did you go through well i
was with the advertising
standards association around disclosure
of advertising and it was at a time when
influencer marketing it wasn't clear
whether you had what you had to write on
influencer marketing posts whether you
ad sponsored whatever i see right and so
there was
and the the rules and the guidelines
were as we were told by someone at the
cma
purposefully vague so that you could
kind of you know interpret
and um they ended up using us as an
example we had a case
uh chundled on i think for nine months
for those nine months we're not sure
whether they're going to shut us down
find us slap on the wrist what's going
to happen it's
tough but it's tough right because you
don't know i don't know right so
it takes a long time yeah that point
around anxiety i think
is um specifically interesting because
um it's
i think it's definitely increasing in
our generation because of social media
and we
all have more tabs open than ever before
ceos are people that as you've alluded
to walk around with all the tabs open
all the time
what do you do to relax in moments like
that when you're in the middle of a
the story i probably don't do a good job
with that you know
i can put a pretty calm face on because
i'm just not naturally like an up and
down person
but you know i try breathing exercises
you know i try to really kind of just
not think about anything sometimes
i tried that calm app yeah i got through
day six of the 30 day challenge
got got a little bored at day seven but
but um
i used to read a lot i used to read a
book a week
i now at this point it's it's it's been
a while since i read a book which is
makes me a little sad this is like my
favorite thing to do
that does work or you just kind of go
for a walk i go on long walks all the
time
that really helps me out a lot i have
some
super exciting news to share with you
all i have an amazing new sponsor for
the podcast which i'm very excited about
called
my energy like with all of the sponsors
on this podcast i've reached out to them
because i truly believe in the
transformative work that they're doing
and that means that i can talk about
them from a place of real authenticity
the company was co-founded by the
brilliant jordan brompton
and lee sutton to give you guys a little
bit of info my energy are one of the
uk's
fastest growing renewable energy
companies whose mission is to reduce our
dependency on fossil fuels
an issue that should be at the forefront
of all of our minds and it's been at the
forefront of mine since i sold my
range rover sport and traded it for an
electric bike
my energy was founded in 2016 and since
then their growth has been absolutely
bonkers
from a team of just six in the uk to a
workforce of over
200 across europe so throughout my
podcast going forward i'll be talking
about some of their products
and showing you how you can make that
transition to a more green future
thank you so much for being a partner
for this podcast my energy and it's our
sponsors ultimately that allow us to
scale things up and
bringing my energy on board is a signal
that this podcast is going to get bigger
the production's going to get better
the guests are going to get bigger the
stories are going to get more compelling
and i couldn't be more excited to share
all of that with you
could you could you talk to me about
what it without going into specifics
about people or whatever
can you talk to me about the um
challenge of
having and sustaining romantic
relationships
while you're also you've got this baby
and this obsession which is all
concerning i think it's like
yeah i think the brain is capable of
kind of filling itself up with certain
things and then
there's just not room for other things
yeah i mean that's how i think about it
yeah i don't know if that's fair and you
know some people would say that that
that
i'm i'm certain that other people can
can can
can fill their brains up with more but
i'm like a very obsessive person right
i don't know if you i'm the exact same
that's why i asked the question because
i was hoping you might be able to tell
me how to fix it i'm not the right guy
to
tell you all that so yeah i i've
struggled for that
same reason just being very
uncompromising with time
and i hear compromise is an important
part to sustaining a healthy
relationship
i heard that too from all of my
ex-girlfriends
but i don't know if like um yeah but i
don't know if like it's also like
you know we do this because you know i
don't know like we're hiding from
something else or like you know
i don't know that's something i think
about sometimes you think about that
a little bit right like why am i so
obsessive but then i think back and i've
always been obsessed about everything
i don't really think it's changed but
when i started my career in business and
i was obsessive looking myself in a room
not really seeing
my friends either i thought this is the
way to live life it's just about get
rich
get um successful and then everything
else
happiness will arrive at that point like
not it would not that i wasn't happy
but just my happiness would it scale to
some point like euphoria
so this is all it so you get successful
you get some money
and you realize that your happiness
probably for me i'm speaking for myself
here
doesn't necessarily scale it doesn't go
down but doesn't
really move upwards that much and then i
start reading about
um the importance of meaningful
connections and relationships and all
these things
are watching this odd ted talk about how
men in relationships over 100 years
study
live longer are happier et cetera et
cetera are more healthy
and i think fact you know what i
actually think i've i've [ __ ] up
i actually think maybe i should have
attributed more time to relationships
but can you can you just be so
intentional about everything i mean
i don't know maybe we can i don't know
but you must you must understand the
importance right according to like the
science anyway of having
yeah yeah yeah but
you know we make the decisions we do i
don't know you know it's all
it's it there's a difference between an
abstraction
and actually what happens right hmm but
you
because i i f worried that i might
regret it someday
that i might have had my priorities
wrong this whole [ __ ] time
you're a young man though does that ever
cross your mind that you might have
miss you might have put your priorities
in the wrong place has it never crossed
your mind
to be honest no really but i'm not a
very
retrospective person at all i literally
don't think about the past
which may not be a good thing either
good for certain things
not good for others what about
friendships then through that through
that
you know chewing glass and staring into
the abyss how good were you at
maintaining
friendships and social
similar thing right it's like you have a
limited amount of time and
i'd say okay okay yeah you know
five out of ten probably five out of ten
i wouldn't recommend
probably it's a lonely job you know and
you're not gonna
you don't want to like hang out with
your friends and just talk about how
tough your day is all
all the time either right so i don't
know if you were the same way
100 awful friend my friends became the
people i worked with
pretty much i had that i heard that but
i think it's really important to
separate that
yeah yeah but it's a solitary thing
right you're a founder
you know you just kind of especially
when greg kind of you know
left the left and so you're just on your
own and you got to figure stuff out
we make this sound kind of like terrible
though i'm just like listen
thing this is this is part of the reason
why i wanted to do this podcast because
i think there isn't uh
there isn't this warning about the
sacrifice it's all
oh my god look he's [ __ ] rich and
he's got oh i'd love to
and i think the balance is important
let me take you up until the the ipo so
you do um
company goes public um our company went
public via reverse merger
things change it's tough um because you
now have the scrutiny of the public
markets
talk to me about that whole journey and
how you found that
um yeah so i think the whole ipo process
you know was it was a lot of work for
about kind of three four months
before the ipo i think we were all kind
of looking forward to
you know something you know really
exciting um and it was
really exciting to take a company public
you know um
you know you know at a big market cap um
you know something coming from an idea
obviously sort of the
the day one you know trading was was
hard right because
i'm not like i don't really like i said
i don't really care that much about what
people think and
i don't really read the media that much
or anything like that but when it's that
pervasive
you know it's like front page of every
you know single newspaper
you know telling you you know you guys
[ __ ] up or you did this
yeah it was tough for a few weeks i'll
be honest with you it was tough for a
few weeks
you know because the market cap fell
yeah and just like you know there's a
lot of you know you you
people in the company oh look what's
going on and you're on investor calls
like what's going on
and ultimately the way i sort of think
about it is
you know so proud of the fact we got
here
right i'm actually just focused on the
business how do we grow the business
how do we move the business in the right
strategic direction right
and i'm super super super optimistic
about the future
for all the stuff we've been doing for
the past few years i'm going to come to
fruition you know in the future and all
the
future facing stuff we're working on now
so if i'm very honest with you
i don't think about the stock price i
actually think about the business
but for a few weeks it was like
difficult right it's very hard
and then there's all these stories we're
in which we talked about a little bit
but
all these stories written about drivers
are they employees are they contractors
um the unique position you've got is
you've actually been a rider and in fact
you still are
yeah i did i did you know five
deliveries last night you know
notting hill and i talk to riders all
the time i know
what they want we're building a business
for our riders for our restaurant
grocery partners for our consumers
that's their custom they're all
customers at the end of the day that's
how we think about it
right so a model that actually works for
them has got to be the most important
thing
and we know our model can it improve
absolutely it can improve we can improve
everything
but do we think it's the best model for
them yeah
100 your company's worth you know
billions and billions and billions and
billions and billions and billions and
you're out last night
doing delivery riders
yeah delivery deliveries around
nottingham why
a few reasons one um i want i always
test our rider app right so it's a good
way to do it
secondly decent way to get some exercise
and you're just on the road and you're
not thinking about anything else
i actually find it very relaxing right
and then thirdly i can actually
kind of see the restaurants in action
too because the interaction is usually
not with the consumer
the consumer doesn't want to talk to you
but they just want their food i get it
the restaurants you can learn a lot just
by spending time there
when you shop at the restaurant to
collect the pizza or whatever it is with
chicken chow mein
do they recognize you no no
one recognizes the writers recognize me
sometimes but no one recognizes i'm not
like a celebrity so
have you ever had an experience where
like a restaurant was rude to you or
like uh
yeah last night really yeah i was pretty
pissed off about did you [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] off the sidewalk no no no
i don't say a word
but i i i make sure to log log into my
notes
really yeah how rude just like
well i was like hey i'm like hey i've
been waiting for a while
they're like they do this and i was like
shake behind you
yeah i'm like come on and then then i
got the food and it was like kind of
cold i'm like hey like
you know just you know this food's kind
of cold and they were like
yeah just deliver it buddy and i'm like
at no point you told them you're this
no i would never you're different from
me no no
but i want the true experience right i
want to understand
what the writers go through it was
really funny as
they were being rude to me there's other
writers walked up to me he didn't know
where i was he was just like oh man you
see
these guys are at it again really yeah
yeah and you take those learnings back
to 100 hq and you go we need to fix this
yeah while we talk to those restaurants
right are you going to speak to that
exact restaurant hundred percent i will
and
what would you say well
i waited around for a long time you
clearly had made the food was just
sitting around like we need better
processes
we need to figure out a way to get this
to work and please tell your staff to
not you know be retweeted
you know and i get it they're busy too
like but
you know it's uh just just smile say hey
how you doing
it makes a big difference in people's
days right what have you
what's your thinking around competition
you're in an incredibly competitive
field where you've got these absolute
heavyweights yeah
and you've had competition emerge and
disappear
throughout your whole course of building
this business and they've and all your
competition seems to have had
10 times 100 times the capital that
you've had oh i don't know we've had a
lot of capital to be fair but i mean
uber
yeah well they're there they always have
a lot and rocket internet in the early
days they launched
in the uk yeah yeah what was that thing
they launched i forget the name but
everyone else yeah food i don't know
something yeah i think it was
look i think competition exists because
this is such
a big market right the it's 1.3 trillion
pounds in the 12 markets we operate in
online penetration is you know call it
three to five percent
it's early it's big market that's why
there's a lot of competition
i think look the way we think about the
competition is um
you know of course we pay attention to
it i mean very closely
but it's really about what is our
consumer value proposition and is it
better than the competition is it
growing on an absolute basis as well
and we fanatically sort of measure that
um and we always think about you know
what is the consumer
the riot or the restaurant the grosser
of the future want before they even know
right what is the answer to that
question what is the future
well i think the future is i can't give
away all my secrets
the future is um look this this this
business is super
underpenetrated on you look look at
travel it's 50
right food is that low why is food
difficult well food's difficult because
a it's perishable and b it's emotional
which means to express food online is
hard you you go to a restaurant right
restaurant's a 75 gross margin business
why low net margin but high growth what
because it's an experience
right right it's an emotional experience
but it's not just about the food it's
what was your relationship with the
maitre d what was what did the core look
like
all these things right i know they're
amorphous how do you take that same
feeling and put it online a really hard
thing to do
so i think the future is going to be
more and more food occasions online
they don't just have to be delivery
though they could be dine in they could
be a whole host of other things
private chefs could could be that could
be you know cool recipe kits could you
know a lot of different things right
but how do you marry that
with the emotional aspect of this
brilliant food industry right
and no one does it we don't do it well
today you look on our app it's pretty
transactional you look at ubers
you look at you know any of these other
guys pretty transactional
and i think the winner in this space
it's a winner i don't know that's that's
maybe a poor word but
but whoever does really really well in
the space is going to
nail that emotional side right the
restaurant generated content
the fmcg generated content the grocery
generated content
we collect millions and millions of
reviews each week on our platform
we don't do anything with that great
today in my view
so how do you marry all that together
how do you migrate the experience from a
transactional one to more of an
emotional one right hmm
interesting this is emotional right here
sorry okay oh you're gonna drink four of
these
that's great for this one so we're gonna
put that all over facebook ads
that's really interesting and so you're
talking about creating greater depth
from what i heard creating
greater depth with that social and
emotional interaction with food
within the food is social food is
emotional right yeah
at the core so delivery is becoming a
social network for food
but i think having aspects of that yeah
right we want to be an app you go to not
just when you're hungry but when you
want to learn about food as well
right i hear you because like a chef
tells his story in a physical
space how do you let that chef tell his
or her story
online and how does that help you make
decisions as to what you want to
purchase right i think that's amazing
and it's really different than buying
like toilet paper on amazon right or
buying like
which is transactional right it's more
transactional now the reason you use
amazon is
the best most reliable service in the
world but i think with food i think it's
a little bit different you need that
reliability but you also need that
emotional connection
wow yeah so that's what we're we're
spending a lot of time on trying to
figure out
so as you look so i guess no i've got
two questions so my next one is about
money
a lot is written when founders go public
about how much money they've made
bonuses blah blah um i mean elon musk is
a great example
the amount they've written about him i
think it caused him to sell all of his
properties and his house in pretty much
all of his possessions
and he now lives a lot of the time when
he's on
a spacex in this little small shed but
he said in the interviews he did that
because
the money is so secondary to him he just
wanted to disarm people from thinking
about that and then obviously when he
became the richest man in the world
again
he is hitting with all the billionaires
or evil stuff
what relationship do you have with money
and what does it mean
to you in your life oh man um
i don't know i never really thought
about it uh
[Music]
i mean i don't really live very
differently than i did
you know seven or eight years ago so
kind of live in the same place
i mean i'd rather more money than less
money probably agree
to be honest um but uh did it make you
happier
i don't know i don't haven't really
thought about it i i
i'm sure there's some i'm sure having
more at some point will make you a bit
happier
mm-hmm right i'm sure as you said
there's probably a limit to that though
right
yeah but i'm not like i don't buy a lot
of stuff
so i don't know like
yeah i just don't buy a lot of stuff so
when you look forward into your future
then
what is it that you're aiming for
and and why does that matter
[Music]
look uh you know um
i think part of me would love to figure
out myself
um uh may sound kind of weird but
just when you start this thing you're on
this
journey and the journey sort of propels
it has a life of its own basically it's
probably the best way to put it
you start getting a lot of customers you
start getting a lot of riders start
getting restaurants you get investors
and
and the things moving and you're moving
along with it
in many cases in a very deliberate way
in many cases
you're along for a journey and so this
thing
has a life of its own and
it it it it is pretty interesting to
take a step back and think okay
is this journey completely everything
that
i had in mind and i wanted to do or were
there just a lot of parts of it that
were
it's like a wave kind of taking you
along
and i'd love to figure that out a bit
to be honest right i don't that makes
any sense
yeah so what i heard was you're trying
to understand if your own personal
journey
is completely aligned with the journey
of the company as as it grows because
the two entities you know especially
i'm guessing at the very start they're
so interlinked
it's your life it's your everything but
at some point you have to kind of
separate
i think not necessarily i'm not saying
resign anything but separate
your life and your ambitions from that
because they're so intertwined and it
becomes difficult i'm not even saying
separate necessarily but just like
having a better understanding
of what your role and what will wants
from his life and what he's interested
in and
yeah and i think i i wonder if other
people feel that way i don't know
maybe you've asked that question i know
how you feel everyone's that sits here
that's a
founder of a big business feels that way
because it's just all consuming
yeah yeah tom sat there last week he
said the same thing did he yeah he's
like he was he was he had a red phone in
his bedroom he was
he had from what he described he had
very little life he mean he said his
relationships broke down
french he said i think his friendships
were okay um but he had this red phone
in his bed
or bedroom that would ring when there
was emergencies he was consumed by it he
had a crushing weight every time he woke
up in the morning
and so now that he's he's left he's now
discovering
pottery and all of these other sort of
personal things that he's doing just for
his own
personal reasons which were probably
impossibly hard to do when he was
being dragged well i think yeah yeah i
think that's interesting yeah when you
start something
and it really becomes something it has a
gravitational pull of its own
and the question is you know are you
this thing or you in the orbit
right yeah it's a little hard sometimes
to to
to separate those two things so that's
something i'd love to kind of understand
how do you go about
understanding that i was going to ask
you man you're the one that talks
oh god a therapist probably and really
trying to i think you're just
talking about it i think because even as
far as i don't think we get much time to
talk about these things
no we're just being dragged by the
emails and the
urgent that's what i mean
so you have to create space right to i
think you have to i think and i think it
will help with business as well
right to take a step back to to remove
yourself and just
like think about other stuff and when
you step back in
that's why i do think going on holiday
is really you know you know it's funny
it's like
i didn't take one for seven eight years
just didn't
um which is like kind of stupid honestly
but maybe in the first few years i could
maybe that was fine
but just having the ability to step away
for a week
and do something totally different i
think is incredibly important
you got any holidays planned for to to
do exactly that this whole travel thing
is
a bit problematic and if you were to go
on holiday do you think you could you
could relax
um it's hard it'll pre it takes me about
three days
so i need to go on a holiday longer than
four days yeah i think that's what i
need to do
yeah well listen um when you do figure
out those
existential uh answers
and you've you've had time to meditate
and go to the beach and
uh figure out that's that point of
separation that you describe
do come back on the podcast and we'll
talk about that then because i'd love to
know the answers
um but i want to thank you for coming
here today and having this conversation
with me thanks steven super fascinating
thank you um and it's so it's so
inspiring
and interesting how there's so many
similarities
with with founders that have gone on
that journey doesn't seem like there's
many differences however the character
that's gone on that journey always seems
to be
really really different and you are you
know remarkably unique so you hear
the same things a oh yeah the like
fundamentals of
the journey and what it does to you and
how it feels is always the same
but then the the differences and the
nuances are in
the like the pilot yeah and how he
addresses the and how he or she
feels about or addresses those that
experience and that usually relates to
the younger years and where you
developed your resilience or your
perspective on the world
um but yeah super fascinating super
inspiring thank you so much for coming
today thank you
now you're a very very busy guy thank
you for the huel
it was delicious i'm not even gonna have
to plug it you've done it all for me
you've done my job thank you
just trying to make it easier you're
right you've made it really easy thanks
thank you appreciate it appreciate you
thank you
[Music]
you